foreign
[Applause]
season came and passed us by and it was
filled with lots of surprise hits but
for now we get what we've been waiting
for here's a video featuring some of the
best fights for anime gave us and I'll
be listing down what I think are the
best battles from shows that I've seen
have you got any bets so far make sure
to lock those in as we get to the list
let's start off with Queen vs Sanju
shall we
foreign
[Music]
piece in 2022 seems to be all about
kaido the epic kaido fight we all heard
about it but I don't want it
overshadowing a fight that can be just
as awesome that's Sanji versus queen
with how much fan Focus has been on
other characters I wouldn't blame you
for not remembering how awesome Sanji
can be but he sure owned this moment
when he saved everyone from Queen it's
finally time for him to shine and the
fight short delivered we get a second
Showcase of powers and all and he did
give us an amazing entrance saving
Chopper the fight is great so far giving
us a glimpse of a gritty and serious
Sanji after all our favorite Playboy
can't be left in the dust considering
how much stronger Luffy and Zara have
become over the years I'm very
emotionally invested in this fight due
to how it looks to be building up
sanji's character I'm expecting a lot of
him and having read ahead and finding
out about the fight's conclusion I'd say
this event really did him Justice now as
of the time of this writing the fight's
not yet finished but with what we've
seen already so far this has all the
Hallmarks of an epic fight that advances
the status quo in a major way
[Music]
[Music]
suleta versus Elon is pretty nice and it
adds some cool World building in the
process
in my opinion an element of a good anime
fight is how it adds a lot to fuel fan
discussion in addition to the actual
fighting itself now it's a bit rare but
it's nice to see when it does happen as
it did with elon's fight against suleta
the first fight is pretty intense and I
really felt it when Elon kept increasing
those permit scores straining himself
more and more in the process
unfortunately for him though the aerial
does show off some new powers ones that
are able to disrupt him and defeat him
in a not so family-friendly way when
suleta called the bit says everyone it
feels that there's something behind that
statement and it's not looking very
pretty the reactions from the fans
afterwards make this fight so good from
a personal perspective the reveals make
for some really nice discussions the
more chill stuff and the foreshadowing
is done and episode 6 of witch from
Mercury seems to be the turning point
it's the point when this becomes the
Gundam series that's on Pace to become
the Talk of the Town it may just be what
the franchise needs for a much needed
Revival
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
up next is Sid vs Xenon
[Music]
I didn't anticipate Eminence and Shadow
becoming as popular as it was but seeing
the show make it actually makes me happy
not that it's mainstream by any means
but it's certainly doing a lot better
than its genre appears over the years
with a lot of promotion a mobile game
and discussions going on in the
community at least where I'm from it's
also got a cool fight in Nifty Showcase
of power in this fight against Xenon yes
this was one that became a meme for like
a week or two awkward line that can
actually turn pretty awesome depending
on your perspective the fight as a whole
is pretty much what you'd expect out of
a show like this it's loud it's chuney
it's over the top and it's full of edgy
Heroes showing off his superiority
against feeble weaklings that dare to
oppose him see it really does a great
job of appearing so called in this seed
I think it's in how the show goes all in
on the tuning element so this show has
become a success it knows it's a popcorn
anime through and through and it makes
no effort to hide it
I'm not charity
and if you thought that that was an
exhibit of crazy overpoweredness how
about the katana Man fight
just what is Katana man made of if you
thought denji and his team were op this
Katana man guy puts everyone to shame
the guy freaking survives everything Fox
devil cursed devil ghost devil
everything his one-on-one with denji is
all sorts of awesome too with music that
goes hard and camera angles that make
the action feel even more intense than
it already is the short exchange is
really cool it all starts with denji
leaping off and beginning the battle and
that grips you and holds you in for the
ride Never Letting Go thanks to the
spectacular animation and how fast and
furious the fight is you know until the
pace slows down when denji decided he
wanted to take a hostage bad idea see
Katana man just being crazy overpowered
as well as the makima scene that follows
which got featured in another video so
make sure you check that out it's quite
an eye-opener to the Grand scale of
things and the chainsaw man Universe
just when he saw dengian allies had
everything in the bag you see monsters
like these roaming around
you go
are any of these fights getting you
going now then go hit that like button
and subscribe to the channel to get more
videos like this to show up in your feed
poochie versus everyone is the finale we
all needed
[Music]
a stone Ocean looks to cap off what's
been a long story spanning Generations
in the JoJo Universe it's just fitting
that we get a final fight like this long
action filled and filled with callbacks
albeit with twists and it's nothing
short of being an emotional
rollercoaster the fight just makes all
the powers come together in an extremely
entertaining Dynamic this anime is just
astounding really reading the fight
chapter after chapter in manga form was
great but seeing the actual attacks
animated with the music helping enhance
the mood it's the only way you can do
JoJo fights Justice it also helps the
poochie make such an engaging final
villain jotara also had a nice Curtain
Call you can tell that he's no longer in
his prime but he's still got it in a way
such a great way for a legendary
character to go out and if you still
haven't had enough of emotional final
fights for characters who've stuck
around for a while you need to stay put
for the next entry
[Music]
as we head towards the end can we talk
about dimple versus psycho helmet
[Music]
we've had a lot of great sidekick times
in the Limelight in anime history before
but this one just takes the cake I don't
think I've ever felt this struck or
invested in a side character in recent
memory but here we have dimple being the
biggest hero we can ever hope for sure
the actual fight is good but this in my
opinion is all about the emotions it's
pretty amazing how awesome this fight is
both in showing off dimples prowess and
culminating his character Arc and
there's no better anime than mob psycho
to animate what an amazing farewell
salutes
[Music]
foreign
versus shigaraki is one of the best
fights this season no questions asked
one villain has consistently remained
one of the most impressive and scariest
threats in another anime is shigaraki
he's definitely not a case of nobody to
nightmare but seeing his Evolution and
what he's capable of since taking the
mantle of being the villain's leader is
something that will send shivers down
any Hero's spine so of course the big
confrontation against him has to have
one of the most drawn out and impressive
showdowns in the whole of my hero
Academia I really love this fight
because it's pretty long but not
unnecessarily drawn out that's just how
fighting a villain of his caliber has to
be and seeing him take on Endeavor
handily while simply overcoming
everything the heroes throw at him is
nothing short of awesome this fight
really did a lot for his character which
has already been thoroughly built up in
terms of prowess it also drives home
that he's pretty much the hero of his
own story with the way he's being
portrayed complete with the combat
mechanics and overcoming the odds
that camps off the list in a nice way
doesn't it so head down to the comments
section and tell me what you think about
the list and if there are any fights
that you think I missed I'm pretty sure
we don't exactly watch the same shows so
there'll likely be stuff that I didn't
get to mention and it's now your time to
show off your recommendations to me
thanks for watching and don't forget to
come back for more anime videos stay
strong stay amazing see you next time